you must have
some kind of vision for your life even
if you don't know the plan you have to
have a direction in which you choose to
go and what i know for sure is that the
biggest choices begin and end with you
your internal big questions who do i
want to be in the world whenever you
feel empty
you go inside yourself and you connect
to the source and you know that all
things are possible
the three things that i want to leave
with you just these three i could do ten
i could do a whole life class but just
these three things will carry you if you
let them first and foremost
knowing who
you
are
knowing who you are
being able to answer this question who
am i and what do i want
i'm asking the bigger question
of who
am i
who am i really my answer is i am god's
child
i am that which is born of all that is
i am as peter schaden said
a spiritual being having a human
experience
come trailing the breath of the
ancestors yet
but trailing the breath of the angels
and understanding that because
i am connected to the source of all that
is
all that is possible is possible for me
that's who i am and what do i want i
don't want to just be
successful in the world i don't want to
just make a mark or have a legacy the
answer to that question for me is i
want to fulfill the highest
truest
expression of myself as a human being i
want to fulfill the promise that the
creator dreamed when he dreamed the
cells that made up me what do i want
you must have
some kind of
vision for your life even if you don't
know the plan you have to have a
direction in which you choose to go i
never was the kind of woman who liked to
get in a car and just go for a ride
what i've learned is that's a great
metaphor for life you want to be in the
driver's seat of your own life because
if you're not life will drive you
so knowing who
you
really are in this space and time that
we embody that's number one what do you
want who are you number two
you must find a way to serve martin
luther king said that not everybody can
be famous but everybody can be great
because greatness is determined by
service now we live in a world where
everybody wants to be famous and where
we admire people for just being famous
we think being known brings us value the
truth is all of that will fade in time
the real truth is that
service and significance
service and the significance that you
bring to your service
is that which is lasting so to be able
to whatever your occupation or job or
talent or gift is our honorees today
getting doctor degrees to
apparently opposite fields hiv and aids
and the spoken word but what they have
in common is service
using the spoken word in service to
community and the world using your
knowledge and information about hiv and
aids and medicine in service to the
world and if you look at all the most
successful people in the world whether
they know it or not they have that
paradigm of service
everybody's talking about mark
zuckerberg and ipo service
jay-z rapping
service
through the word to people through song
for many years i was really just happy
to be on tv and people would stop and
say oh you on tv yeah i'm on tv i like
being on tv it's a nice job and it was
about the time that i received my
honorary doctorate from spelman around
1993 so i don't know if that had
something to do with it i thought of
myself as dr winfrey that i went back
and i took a long look at what it was i
was doing on
on tv and made a decision that i was no
longer going to just be on tv but i was
going to use tv as a platform as a force
for good and not be used by tv and i
will tell you my decision to make that
significant change in the way i operated
on television using television as a
service
changed my career exponentially service
through
medicine service through art
using whatever it is you produce your
product as a way of giving back to the
world
when you shift the paradigm of whatever
it is you choose to do to service and
you bring significance to that
success will i promise you follow you
service
and significance
equals success that's number two number
three it's so simple but so hard to do
always
do
the right thing
be excellent people notice think of how
you notice you go to taco bell somebody
gives you extra napkin and some sauce
you notice you want to go back to that
person because even at taco bell
excellence shows itself be excellent
let excellence
be your brand
everybody talks about building a brand i
never even knew what that was
when people say your brand i would say
no i'm just oprah what i recognize now
is that my choice to in every way in
every example in every experience to do
the right thing
and the excellent thing is what has
created the brand
and what i know is that when you are
excellent you become unforgettable
people remember you you stand out
regardless of what it is and that is
what we all want we want to be
unforgettable and not forgettable so
doing the right thing
even
[Music]
when nobody knows you're doing the right
thing will always bring the right thing
to you
i promise you that why because the third
law of motion is always at work for
every action there's an equal and
opposite reaction that is so true in all
of our lives so you don't have to worry
about revenge or getting back at
somebody making sure
they pay
you just have to do the right thing and
the right thing will follow you even
when people don't support it i remember
many times on my show there are many
shows y'all never saw and the reason you
didn't see them is because i
got the last vote and i remember
2010 my team hardest working team in
television had done this interview with
a woman who turns out she was a sunday
school teacher by day and a sex addict
at night they were like you won't
believe it we got her going out we got
her with the men and we get to show her
and she was willing to show us
everything
i sat down with a woman for an interview
that was taped and during the process of
the interview i said why are you doing
this
and she said oh i want to help people i
want to tell my story and i want to help
people i said do you have children she
says yes i have a 10 year old son
i knew right then this is never going to
see the light of day so we got off the
air and i said to the lady we are not
going to air that show and she said why
my producer said why
she knew she was being filmed she knew
what she was saying she knows what you i
said because her son will never get over
it
her son will never get over it and it's
not worth a rating point to me not worth
the rating point to me to know that
there's a ten-year-old boy who's
destroyed because his mother went on the
oprah winfrey show and told all her
business
you do the right thing
even when other people think it may not
be and oftentimes when you make a
decision to do the right thing
immediately you're faced with doubt is
that the right thing was that the right
decision i don't know is that the right
thing you always know it's the right
thing when in the end
there is peace
you are rewarded by peace
the most important thing i have come to
know in doing the right thing and making
the right choices there's a price that
comes with that people don't always like
you and they're not always happy for you
and if you surround yourself with people
who are not accustomed to your success
they become fearful they become scared
because you are reflecting back
something to them that they don't
recognize
that only happens when you are around
people who do not mean
and want
and aspire to the best for you
people who want the best for you want
you to be your best so my greatest
advice to you is to surround yourself
with people who are going to fill your
cup until your cup runeth over
and what i know for sure is that the
biggest choices begin
and end with you your internal big
questions who do i want to be in the
world
my relationship to source energy to all
that is god i'm not talking about what
you believe in god i'm talking about
your experience
of that which is all life
which is divine and universal i'm
talking about a big deal being connected
and aligned with that when you are
tuned in and charged into that whenever
you feel empty
you go inside yourself and you connect
to the source and you know that all
things are possible and to choose to do
the right thing
in service
and significance i promise you
you will create a vessel of service for
yourself first because you have to honor
yourself first you have to give to
yourself first otherwise you have
nothing to give away
you will create a vessel for yourself
for your family your community and the
world
and those
three things
will not only lead you to a blessed life
i stand as a witness my life is so
blessed i can't even take it in
sometimes
it will lead you not just to a a gifted
life and a rewarding life that fills you
up
but a sweet life
that's what you want you want the
sweetness
you want it to be so sweet
so that even when the storms come and
they will you'll know
this too shall pass
this too shall pass
the storm is passionate and you shall
not be moved because you know who you
are
you